morning routines
ken what is your morning routine it
better wake you be waking up with an
eight pack
yeah i mean i wish i mean i wake up like
like the eight pack you know
chicken tender meal from kfc that's what
i do you know what i'm saying
oh yeah i forgot you're from the south
yeah my morning routine is not going to
bed until like 2 a.m because watching
one piece and trying to catch up to all
the episodes
hell yeah do you watch anime on 16 times
speed
no i should every day i wake up and i
watch anime that's basically my morning
really oh my god it's the best i always
watch it late at night
all the kids and everything in the house
i gotta wait until everybody's in the
bed and that's your time
and then i stay up way too late because
i want to extend my alone time you know
i'm too tired to read subtitles at night
wait a minute you watching dubs
no subtitles bro okay
i'm reading i don't get too tired to
read all right who's too tired to read
well not you apparently
not these guys either baby
all of them all of them are shirtless i
love it it's great
they're like a different breed these
people you've seen american psycho right
yeah yeah yeah it's like they're all
trying to do that patrick baitmanship
like my moisturizing face still cream
costs 400 dollars
it helps to keep my cleansed skin a
perfect glass shape at all times
i wake up and they all seem to have this
competition of
who can wake up the earliest night i
wake up at six
an idiot i wake up at 5 30. oh you [ __ ]
lazy piece
i wake up at four [ __ ] you
still have to sleep eight hours
you know that right it doesn't matter
when you wake up am i the only one that
thinks this it's not like you get more
out of hours in the day because you wake
up early
you still have to [ __ ] sleep you
gotta go to bed earlier these these
they're just living yeah exactly
exactly but that's when i get my
grinding all right let's just watch it
because they're all in the [ __ ] same
day
okay here 5 30. yeah yeah wake up 5 30.
hey guys
and welcome back to the channel in
today's video i'm going to run you
through my full
morning routine he's a fan of dream
minecraft
i knew it dude this dude's named karen
he's got like the love
live like thing they're all so normies
aren't
normal man oh my god the most
interesting thing about this dude is he
wakes up at 5 30 in the morning
you think that all right it has abs this
yeah it's completely bright outside as
well
i've seen this video and i gotta warn
you crouch crouch shot coming in
meditation music to wake me up
i'm sure i set up small things to make
my life a little bit easier when waking
up
my laundry yeah yeah
no just prepare your what you're wearing
the day before no
i mean the ultimate way is to just wear
the same t-shirt every day
i wake up in the morning whatever i took
off the night before is laying beside my
bed and i put it back on
me too and it's the best they're in the
same short socks and everything
i got the same socks i've been wearing
for like three days right now
these [ __ ] idiots they pick it up
today before
oh my god oh man i mean the thing is
i i work out like around 11 or some [ __ ]
yeah so then i shower and then i change
my clothes exactly that's the way that
you change your clothes when you
when you take a shower like it's gonna
work out while i put on some fresh clean
clothes you're just gonna sweat it
double laundry dumbasses
i usually wake up around 6 30 seven in
the first
perfect hair
[Laughter]
6 37 that's very precise i gotta give it
to him
usually around like more or less six
thirty seven forty seconds or something
like that
i give myself a little bit of you know
extra 40 seconds of uh relaxing
i don't know about you guys but i wake
up feeling dehydrated every morning so
this
i don't know about you guys but i drink
water sometimes i get
i don't sometimes i just get thirsty
it's crazy yeah grease that fiji water
you know
only the best from my body my body's a
tip yeah gotta make gotta make sure i
show people
that like i drink fiji water look at
this [ __ ] skip
lately i've been working out around 9 00
a.m so that gives me about two hours to
get some work done at home
before i exercise so i light up the
scandal which by the way smells
incredible it's the gin
man it's a [ __ ] candle dang the
gentleman's land
sponsored but hell yeah to be fair
there's a stigma against men with
candles all right but
i wouldn't [ __ ] lit a candle ain't
nobody got time for that [ __ ]
oh yeah i remember it the candle cost
over 100 bucks
search for it nice i only use candles
that cost at least 100 bucks because
otherwise
what's the [ __ ] point
[Music]
the past few weeks i've been working on
the upcoming forte series sponsor
oh my god how many sponsors are in this
video jesus christ
we need a sponsor they will launch this
december they're coming there's new
products coming in december
can't wait what's that picture
does he have it's a fan art he has a
picture of himself
with his award
hey i mean if he's proud
hey if he's proud of his award i mean
fair enough who needs a reward
it's inside towards his inside look at
this ken you see the problem with this
what's the problem what's the problem
this is not an ergonomically
well structured setup all right the
laptop's top screen needs to be line of
sight with his eyes
they're clearly way [ __ ] up he's
gonna have beta posture
if he keeps
[ __ ] [ __ ] i bet he wakes up at like
6 38 or some dumb [ __ ]
after a couple of hours of work and
catching up on emails
you see that smile yeah oh there's black
i see it there it is oh he's got time
and i get my pre-workout ready so that i
can have the energy i need to crush
this workout i've been drinking this one
here from transparent labs and i
highly recommend it i'll leave a link
here if you guys are interested
if you guys are looking for something to
do the thing is like i watch so many of
these
i'm like it's a weird balance of me
thinking it's ridiculous but also like
oh i kind of want that i could
i could have i could probably use that
and there's usually not a lot of people
around so it's safe
and i get a nice tan as a bonus so why
not it's like an endless flex video
i mean that's what they are yeah it's
like
oh man didn't markiplier do a video like
this of like i don't want a
dog on markiplier but like they do these
videos where they talk about like
what they do in a day but they never
address like this is like the ultimate
day they have right i doubt anyone lives
like this day by day
go away i got i got a lot of houses
everything i do in a day
6 28. uh well he's got the other guy
beat man
i i have my alarm set for 6 30 every
morning i can get out of bed
as early as like 6 45 that's pretty much
the earliest that i'm
out and up because i try to wake up
while i'm still laying down keep
when do you wake up i actually know
because i always harass you
once you wake up you know yeah i was
like
where the [ __ ] is can i need to shoot a
[ __ ] video
uh well my alarm goes off every morning
at 8 am
and i never ever get up at my alarm
i go right back to sleep and i get out
of bed around 10. yeah
unless you specifically have to be
somewhere then no
don't i'm not leaving yeah i just go out
because i have to walk the dogs
otherwise i would stay in bed i shower
after my workout i don't know
what's an average sharp five minutes i
don't know however long five minutes
dude i sit in the shower for an hour if
i can whenever i had them build the
house i live in now i'd
had them put a bench in my shower so i
could sit down oh [ __ ]
yeah i want that yeah my son made fun of
me for wanting a chair in there in the
shower
oh my god yeah even the guy that like
the construction guy was like why you're
just gonna sit here and they fall on you
like good i'm like
yeah yeah that's quality time yeah
that's quality time
so i get my thinking done all right i
love sitting in the shower dude
i even got them to put the hot water
heater that's like it's like gas and it
doesn't run out
like it's infinite hot water dude oh i'm
living in luxury over here man
the planet is dying but i feel good hell
yeah
hell yeah god i get
five minutes i mean perhaps i i tried to
do one of those cold showers for a while
but our showers doesn't even get that
cold so it's not even
like i can't even do it but it's
supposed to be really good for you dude
i don't wanna keep telling a bunch of
stories but we gotta we also have a
bidet like mary
we got like the attachment for our
toilet oh you gotta [ __ ] pay that
amen
dude that's it main reason why i go to
japan so i don't have to wipe my ass
anymore it's not
warm so it's like super cold outside
like there's ice on the ground
that sounds
that's that's some real wake-up [ __ ] you
should make your morning routine oh my
god every day
break cold water
it really kicks in i don't need caffeine
anymore
i just used to cold water in my ass
[Music]
around eight o'clock is when my video
goes up uh so you know i can check
comments on that i can make sure that it
went up okay
that's the nice thing about living in
lake because you can publish the videos
in like a not obnoxious time
oh yeah like i have to publish my at six
or five and it's like dude i just wanna
chill
don't even think about that yeah yeah
mine's really not like 11 right
now yeah so early for you jesus i'm
actually impressed he said he reads the
comments like
you don't really i love reading comments
i mean i read some of the comments i
read like the upvoted comments right
because those are the ones that will
actually give you actual feedback about
the video and stuff like that like if
you misspelled something or something
when you get too deep you start getting
into felix why do you have that cinnamon
toast king guy in your video he's so
annoying and i can't
yeah you so you sort by new you get the
morons yeah
oh god like here this dude is crazy
it's 9 o'clock that's when my team will
start bothering me
i say team i don't really work with them
on a day-to-day basis i'm talking about
my manager
agent assistant lawyers all those people
youtubers they are not part of my
[ __ ] team let me tell you that hey
laurie if you're watching
i like you you're not my team right
that's a weird way to phrase it on my
team
i wish i had a team you are me i don't
have a team felix you're my team
you're my you're my baby you're you
don't have a lawyer
uh i've never needed one that's the most
purest thing i've ever heard in my life
dude well
god bless you ken yeah in a perfect
world that will be my worst
my editor works just to make the videos
that go on youtube that's basically just
me
my team is working on the deals for
bigger projects helping me coordinate a
heist with markiplier stuff
uh any anything bigger than just you i
kind of like that he's referring to it
as a team
my brand manager if you're watching this
i like you you're not part of you're
part of the bro
army nation i should pitch that anytime
i
get like a new realtor or some [ __ ] dude
you're party
you're broke
[Laughter]
of course i've forgotten xyz because i
wasn't
see this is the problem i have with
assistance you still have to do this
[ __ ] they're just there to tell you to
do this [ __ ] oh
well maybe my friend is mary then
because she reminds me of everything
that i forget
it helps me out a lot well that that's
good
that's good obviously but like every
time i complain if i'm busy everyone's
like why don't you just get in the
system like they
trust me it doesn't help it's just an
ego thing that people have to give them
coffee or some [ __ ] like that right
right oh i have an assistant let me let
me get my assistant to mail you these
things that will take me two seconds to
do myself because i don't want to do it
screw that i don't well i don't i just
don't find that it actually saves time
i got a very serious question these are
okay these morning routine videos the
dudes are flashing their abs and being
attractive
what do you think is the actual appeal
of this video the markiplier one no no
just in zero the whole all of them
but they they appeal i don't know and
like it seems like a fantasy
like people think right i procrastinate
just the same as everybody else does
uh where where
when you shower for five minutes my dude
don't don't appropriate my laziness okay
how dare you like i'm not immune to it
but i know that because i have such
limited time i can only do so much
i'll stop for like a meal break i'll
come down he
eats oh my god
what is that is that like a bacon and
ketchup sandwich
that looks good i'll eat that i don't
need meat but that looks good
oh you don't eat meat yeah you see ken
i am what's called a pescetarian
it's re it's for many reasons by mainly
i just care about the environments
and the souls of the animals and that
does not necessarily put me in a better
bracket or above anyone else but
i just feel bad for i just have a lot of
morals
and i just care more i just care more
than other people and i can tell her
that markiplier clearly does not care
about
other people as much as i do
so uh he even though he doesn't
procrastinate
i am above mark and everyone else
for that matter thank you
ken like 8 30 ish i tried to go for a
run
i've been running up to an hour i hate
running i hated running
um man works out twice a day god damn
jesus did we fight running at night is
really great because you have all these
endorphins that come up and you're just
like
i can [ __ ] run like crazy when i was
into running yeah
running a nice screen anymore i run with
uh zombies run
so it's like this story where it's like
randomly zombies can start chasing you
when you're out on a run and it's dark
and i only play spooky music
and so it's like really scary so i'm
just out in the middle of my
neighborhood
and it'll be like ding ding warnings off
that sounds awesome
i want to try that what is wrong with it
what is wrong with you people what do
you mean you go out like running light
and play scary music and have zombies
chase you
that sounds cool what
that will make you more like oh [ __ ] you
zombies oh my god i gotta get out of
here
well zombies are slow there's nothing oh
dude whenever you were into running do
you ever do the thing to where like
you you see something in the distance
and you give yourself that timing like i
gotta get there
in the next 10 seconds or i'm going to
die or something like that
no what now is that
is that how you do it yeah is that how
you get through it
i think i told you this stuff but like
one time i was into really long distance
and i remember passing this uh woman
that ran with her stroller
yeah and then like 30 minutes i just
hear like
behind me like what the [ __ ] is behind
me and then i
look over and i see the same woman like
trying
so hard to catch up with me
like you can tell she's had this
struggle for so long i'm like trying to
be like this [ __ ] guy
past me i'm not gonna like just [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and i just like
you not happening i wasn't even trying
oh my god you you had that you had to
raise against the
woman with their babies rolling it's
stroller
it's not fair at all but it was
hilarious and i felt
so good i don't know why would you wear
pajamas a bit it wasn't like super cold
that night but
it feels uncomfortable i don't like
things wrinkling all over me so i don't
yes oh my god the wrinkles oh my god no
one speak
okay i gotta be quiet here all right
okay
marzia doesn't care if the sheets aren't
straight
like here can you believe this well i
mean
i live with a savage it doesn't bother
me
it doesn't bother me either but mary
can't stand
the sheets not being straight yes they
have to be straight
like mary i am so sorry i am so sorry
mary
i can't believe this [ __ ] you're like
one of them
you're one of them we have a weighted
blanket right and if he like pulls the
blanket up and like the sheet comes out
from the bottom of the bed and goes over
oh
my god we have to make the whole bed yes
obviously obviously
oh my god dude all right we got david
david this is shorter i want to go
through this
okay hi i'm 74 he does not wake up at 4
21.
420 is a meme 420. uh
that's hilarious and this is everything
i do in a day
what is that the audio on this thing it
sounds awful i wake up every day around
i don't know 9am ish i say nice all
right
we got the relatable guy here there we
go after hitting snooze
about 12 or 16 times i go
and go to the bathroom first thing i do
is i usually take a shower take a shower
every morning i brush my teeth in the
shower
which i know is kind of weird i shave i
do everything in the shower
what is wrong with this person he has
like 20 alarms go off before he wakes up
at 9am and then goes brush his teeth in
the shower
jesus christ what's the problem
do you brush your teeth in the shower
yeah it saves time
we just talked about how you like to sit
in the shower for like 20 minutes and
now you're trying to save time in the
shower by brushing your teeth in it but
it's
boring to brush your teeth i don't like
doing it he's 100 right and marcie made
fun of me for doing it too
as she should have because i hate i
don't give a [ __ ] i brush my teeth in
the shower
can't stop me because then you can just
spit wherever you want it's amazing oh
you probably pee in the shower too don't
you
not
mean no
i don't it all goes down the same drain
right yeah i am vegetarian
ken you cannot polish me sorry about
apologies
and i turn the shower off and when i
hear the final drops
in the shower i take the water and i
spit it into my hand here
you can spit anywhere that was the point
of the shower dave
what are you doing don't spit in your
hands
he takes a shower and turns it off then
spits all over himself
now he he waits for the last drop and
then he spits
and i let it drop on the ground and i'm
hoping
that this is this sounds nuts and i'm
hoping that the drop from my hand is
louder than the last
pieces of water that fell out of the
shower does that make sense i know this
sounds absolutely insane but i lose
every time
and if i don't have the splash of water
be loud i have to redo the whole cycle
enough to turn the shower on
my man you got ocd isn't that energy
yeah i think that's ocd isn't he
like when you have to do a certain thing
a certain way right
i mean all right so stupid i feel like a
psychopath
and then and then when i get out of the
shower i take
oh you're making fun of his illness now
again not me i'm just agreeing
okay and i put it back in the cup where
it sits by the sink so i have it for the
night time
but instead of placing it there i always
like oh my god it keeps going
and if i get it in that that
to me it means i'm gonna have a good day
i know this all sounds crazy i sound
like a groundhog
like looking at my shadow and be like oh
but that's that's kind of another thing
i
uh i live by i like to put my
seems like he's hold that in for a while
yeah why is he he's he's really venting
here he's really letting his feeling
thing out here
damn i feel bad clothes on in the
bathroom
um because i'm scared that i'm gonna
come out naked and my friends are gonna
be there with like
a flamethrower or something to scare me
so i i get completely ready in the
bathroom so when i come out i'm camera
ready just in case somebody's already
filming me
when i'm done yeah isn't that because he
did that to other people
like prank them in the shower and [ __ ]
so now he's living this paranoid like
i'm dressed
i usually go out to the living room
around around like 10 30. i usually have
tea to start out my mornings
i i don't even really like the taste of
tea but i like holding something warm in
my hand like
this is this guy like a robot that's
just trying to pretend to be a human or
something
why would you have tea and not drink it
i just like to hold it and pretend i'm a
person
hello everyone i am totally a normal
person i did not just spend 20 minutes
in the shower trying to get my spit
correct
this comment right there this is the
most realistic daily what
[Laughter]
well that's people's morning routines
what is your morning routine
tell us in the comments because i read
them okay
i'm like ken i mean
i'll i'll read some of them